what were the challenges of telling a
story this way in having 90 minutes with
no dialogue well the we made a TV series
was shown which we're still making and
it has no dialogue we wanted to stick to
the integrity of the series really seem
to work very well and some of the best
episodes are quite cinematic they're
quite like many films and I think what
tempted Martin the co-director was the
fact was the idea of making the modern
day silent movie because we so used to
films with dialogue it was really nice
to get into that frame of mind where
you're telling a story purely through
images and that was a challenge bit of a
scary challenge the start but a very
satisfying want to achieve what's the
challenge then to hang this on Sean when
he's kind of the star of the series what
what did you what were some of the
challenges you used to develop the
larger story I think we we sort of made
two decisions fairly early on what one
was that we'd start the story in the
world of the TV series yeah which is on
the farm and the cactus people knew and
they would have to take it to a new
world like and the world of the city but
was a kind of fairly obvious idea in
terms of its the opposite at the
countryside and we thought as a good
canvas for some fun gags and I think the
second decision was that we needed to
give the characters a big emotional
story to engage the audience and
actually there is a lot of emotional you
know there is emotional stories in the
series but we kind of but in a way the
series is more like a workplace in that
you've got a kind of boss farmer and
you've got kind of form and Bitzer and
you've got a rum the cheaper like
workers so we kind of reimagined it is a
kind of family metaphor with a sort of
absent father figure and the bits of the
dog is the kind of eldest sibling and
Sean's the kind of malcolm in the middle
and I think that gave us an opportunity
to tell a more emotional story about
about a kind of in a way a family needs
to you know remember that they love each
other and stop taking each other for
granted Sean seemed to me like it was a
bit of a shift in that it it wasn't the
big features that you've been doing
the same time it was a feature-length
film and so talk about setting up what
would work for this particular project
clearly shown the ships are very
well-rehearsed production because the
animators come off the TV series came
into the future it's they understand
their campus very well so in terms of
production that wasn't going to be
anything new this could mean all of it
and a few more characters in it so then
then it becomes having got the script
woodman fact these two guys who both had
long hair when they started writing the
film it was quite quite hard to get it
you know we always done a line of
dialogue no we can't have a line of
dialogue having got the script down and
the storyboard done on the story real
done you'll then go into the logistics
which is and these films are quite big
logistical exercises because we had 30
odd sets on this a lot of animators
because the way in which you produce the
film in a reasonable amount of time is
to obviously multiply up the number of
units you've got and it was a same sir
way that we were on TV series and then
interestingly not having dialogue also
meant it was much quicker to do as well
because we weren't having to write me
write dialogue and we call dialogue and
do line selects and editing huge amount
of work that goes into dialogue
particularly an animated film that was
kind of taken away which sped up all
sorts of things particularly a few
reshoots that we didn't know and if you
pick up shots at the end and fact the
pickup shots were almost shot before
they've been storyboarded because the
sets run on the studio floor the guy's
not needed to be done we didn't have to
go no finally actor record a new line
going to booth land selects so we could
just jump in and we just to give um you
know a shout out to our voice artists
because they were voice artists we did
actually record people and it was for
them or slightly surreal experience
because we sort of said as far as we're
concerned you know when we were called
in we could be making billions of
bridges of madison county we're taking
this absolutely seriously and then we
almost get into discussing emotional
ideas within what the characters were
going through and then we'd sake but can
you do it by grunting or mumbling and
they roasted the challenge so it was
quite hard for them but you write the
actual process of animating was much
easier so so Dave number two here so not
to confuse your as a cinematographer and
you're doing
the same thing with your lights that a
live-action shoot would do which is
lighting because you act actually
three-dimensional sets so at what point
do you come into this and generally we
wait until the set dressers coming they
put the sets up there and they're
constructed the set dressers coming will
start distressing them which is about
the time we start looking at mesirow and
we'll start putting a basic lighting in
there when the sets of finish being
dressed and then we'll do the sort of
fine lighting in there and it is exactly
the same as with live-action I mean I've
had this at the past's I think even
going back to wrong trousers people
coming and say I'm it's wonderful that
the Lighting's really good it's like a
real film and we think it but it is what
is it is a real film you've applied the
same thing you want to put mood in there
you want to put tension you want to make
it interesting it has to support the
storyline and so you you treat it as it
would anything else obviously there are
practical limitations with a lighting as
the way you can put the lights and
although in general stop frame i find it
it's actually more flexible you've got
more time you can use any exposure you
like we're not tied to 50th of a second
needle very bright lights we could work
with quite low light levels a lot of the
lights we use rhtdm which fact using
like shop fitting lights because they're
actually small and to the scale of the
characters for larger scenes will be
using maybe up to 10 KS because
basically at the end of the day outside
it's the Sun or it's the moon so all the
lighting principles as a normal apply so
ill on I want to talk to you about the
the music on this because even though
this is a silent film of style you have
some songs come in with lyrics and so at
what point was that chosen as a way to
go and and how would the placement of
those work out for you well that was the
first job was to write feels like summer
um the the opening title song because
that was weaved into the score and then
the Sheep sing it and then it comes back
at the end so it was it was this very
integral part part of the film and
and we wrote that was the third feels
like some was the third version of the
song so you know where there are a few
attempts to get it right but that was
the first job and then after that we had
to do the Sheep singing it and and
because they couldn't film that scene
until until we had a recording of that
so as you're working on this film that
one of the things that strikes me is
there these places that are seem very
Vista like the city and the country to
you were you're seeing a large landscape
can you talk a little bit about how that
is is achieved well they were quite
large sets and we had one set the
weather sheep come out into the city
square and I think we had and we had one
animator animating at 42 characters so
that one person having to run if we
didn't have the digital technology I
don't know how the hell he would have
remembered which character he'd actually
just moved but he was heading 42 there
but they were just quite big sets for
this for the traffic ones on the on the
road going into the city we did have to
do several passes because we couldn't
make that many vehicles so which the
lane going to the right the lane going
to the left and the flyover separately
and just blend them together but
basically big sets so here our guest
stars and what are they made of well
this one has got this is actually
silicon he's a silicon model his face is
made out of cannabis plants in clay and
the mouths and you pop out so we have
substitute mouths that you then blend in
the join but it's a silicon model with
an armature in a sort of Ray Harryhausen
tradition of armatures right use latex
but silicones really really great but if
you think you just as you'd actual
models it's sarah and sean its natural
sean and remember that one or two of the
shots his eyes filled screen so in one
or two of the shots that that was the
entire
I mean except up as sharp lens like and
further than heavy there's a lot of
metal in them oh wow yes this is quite a
berry what a complex metals metal is
very very ya lousy animators to really
put a lot of performance into them
entire second so how do you keep them in
place they were they well some of them
have got what we call tie downs i don't
know with that we could have Sean there
we put little screws in underneath ok
sometimes you use Larry left magnets so
the asset is a perforated steel set Bay
often and you put underneath a magnet
which holds them down very very tightly
so they have little choice pockets on
the back in which you can put in a kind
of a steel rod which will be connected
to a kind of a heavy weight so that'll
actually take the weight of the model
off the feet so you can actually you
don't have to weigh so much about
balancing and or actually tying them
down because the weights taken bio rig
so making all these puppets is like its
own set of work it's a huge it's a huge
endeavor I mean the design and they're
all handmade by in the unspoken heroes I
mean other topic makers and and the
riggers actually can some of the rigging
gets very complicated as well yeah and
you might have to read multiple
characters and so on so there's a whole
department that does model and of course
you're doing I don't know how many
farmers we made for this film again
there were farmers in different stages
of dress and undress as well and there
was a naked farm and I was like one
naked farmer if you spot the nice so
there's a it becomes quite a literary
production because they are having two
are quite mass-produces models but make
a lot of each character and find a
process which is relatively easy to make
them in and is going to produce a
character which is going to be really
good to animate well I've gone over but
I thank you all for being here and I
hope you had a good time hearing about
the making of this film that
congratulations gentlemen hope you have
a big success with it